bonsoir jean marie le pen n'a pas pu
mener sa campagne électorale en corse ce
matin impossible pour le président du
front national
d'atterrir alors prévu à bastia des
nationalistes avaient envahi l'aéroport
ce soir le meeting qu'il devait tenir
ajaccio était interdite une mesure prise
par la préfecture afin d'éviter de
nouveaux troubles jean baptiste prédit
jean marie le pen manifestants
nationalistes arbitré par les forces de
l'ordre prête que le résumé de la
journée mouvementée du leader du front
national encore une journée ponctuée
d'incidents deux heures durant de petits
groupes de manifestants ont affronté les
policiers dans les rues d'ajaccio bilan
quelques blessés légers pendant ce temps
talent de réunion en état de siège 200
sympathisants qui attend leurs leaders
19h45 l'interdiction officielle du mi6
et signifié à jean marie le pen ambiance
tendue à quelques centaines de mètres
les sympathisants doivent se faire une
raison jean marie le pen a déjà regagné
son hôtel protestation devant médias
je trouve scandaleux jeudi via
scandaleux que ce soit les policiers et
la police aux ordres du préfet bien
évidemment je n'engage pas la
responsabilité personnelle de ce genre
là et l'arrivée des gendarmes mobiles
casqués tout cela faisait partie d'un
scénario qui est évident pour peu les
incidents auraient fait oublier l'objet
de la visite les élections régionales
encore le conditionnel obtient pont plus
faibles scores dans les combats